Florida Governor Ron desantis's not yet
even a real campaign campaign might
already be collapsing uh Ron appearing
with Casey DeSantis and they tell a very
coordinated story about how you know
they had a Disney wedding or something
but it was all before they fell in love
at Disney but it was all before Disney
went woke one day she comes to me and
says you know she comes to me with tears
in her eyes and she says sir talking to
my parents and and they were interested
in potentially doing the wedding at Walt
Disney World
oh you said you could do it however
no Mickey Donald Duck anybody at the
wedding ceremony this is really not
helping DeSantis he's in South Carolina
telling Disney stories while Florida is
in chaos due to flooding and gas lines
and meanwhile when he is in Florida he's
just obsessed with Disney World